The Silver Reed YC6 Yarn Changer is
designed to be used for both
single and double bed knitting.
In comparison, for Brother machines,
there are separate color changers
for single and double bed.
Just so you don't get confused as I'm
recording this, I may use the term color
changer and yarn changer alternately.
I mean the same thing.
Start by tilting the bed
by using the ribber clamps.
Even if you're going to be using the color
changer for single bed knitting,
you need to tilt the bed so
the device fits in place.
Once the bed is secure with the ribber
clamps, make room for the color changer
by pushing the sponge bar to the right.
It'll protrude 2 to 3 CM on the right
side, and it'll remain in this position
as long as the color changer is in place.
Loosen the setting wheel until it stops.
This is releasing the setting plate
that will be inserted into the needle
bed where the sponge bar normally lives.
Insert that setting plate and wiggle
it around until it seats.
At the same time, push the color changer
towards the right until the edge
of that yarn changer sits firmly
against the end of the bed.
Push the release button to align all
the holder buttons to the "O" position.
When I got my color changer,
this holder was all the way out.
I gently pulled it out a little more,
felt a click, and then released it.
The spring brought it back into position.
By pushing the release button,
it aligned that holder with the others.
In this position,
all the holders are out of work. Again,
because this color changer can be used
in two ways, we need to align it into its
correct position for how we're knitting.
For single bed knitting,
loosen the change screw and push
the arm up, and then tighten the screw.
For double bed knitting, loosen
the change screw and let the arm drop.
Then tighten that screw again
to secure the changer arm.
Next, we'll set up the tension mast.
Snap the tension guide onto the yarn rod
or the yarn mast and slide it down
to secure it so it doesn't twist around.
Carefully pull up the tension spring
of the tensioner assembly
and snap it into position.
Insert the yarn rod or that mast
into the front slot of the tensioner.
It insert the lower end of the yarn rod or
mast into the slot in the needle bed
and rotate it so it's
secure and doesn't twist.
Next, exchange the knitter connecting
sinker plate with the yarn changer arm
and you're ready to start
using your yarn changer.